émond soir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
évidemment avec et loire où l'enjeu bon
soirée loi bonsoir bonsoir à tous et
nicolas valait 1 invités guest star
bonsoir la grosseur stéphane gros spoil
loi à savoir nicolas la valise on
appelle donc aux webmasters de la tour
infernale est maintenant aussi tu
t'occupes du site dont diagonale qui vit
exactement les deux secondes peut-être
bien oui donc un nouveau site est
apparue sur le web donc on la présentait
la semaine dernière diagonale tizi point
com são 200 e
donc c'est une véritable base de données
au niveau des émissions on peut faire
des recherches avec des mots clés et
bien en tant que bientôt la leçon pas
mal de choses on bientôt bouger sur le
site donc diagonale tv.com voilà vous
rappelle ou pas c'est évidemment qui est
notre émission qui s'appelle diagonale
la leçon qui est présentée par bertrand
guyard et loire lange qui donne des
cours d'échecs donc tous les lundis à 10
heures et accessible évidemment à la
demande va passer tout de suite à notre
première rubrique de ce soir l'événement
de la semaine
voilà donc l'événement de la semaine
avec nicolas donc on en parlait tout à
l'heure il ya deux choses alors d'abord
évidemment on va revenir sur la
qualification de joël lautier au zonal
même si ça fait c'était la fin de la
semaine dernière mais c'est quand même
actualité de la semaine dernière parce
qu'il ya eu notamment une conférence de
presse aujourd'hui à clichy à clichy et
un deuxième événement c'est une lettre
ouverte de la fidh et care rappeur rohff
lui-même pour éventuellement revenir
réunifier les dit alors exactement
premier thème tu vas tu nous en parler
de cette lettre ouverte pendant cette
conférence de presse donc de le
joaillier qui s'est déroulé il ya deux
trois ans voilà c'est ça donc on a été
avec ont été invités avec et loire où
l'ange donc joël lautier et igor nataf
qualifier pour le championnat du monde
donc faisait l'objet d'une conférence de
presse
donc à clichy avec jean-claude moins gai
et tout le monde de clichy donc c'était
vraiment très sympa et je crois qu'on va
pouvoir voir quelques petites images
tout à l'heure donc non pas tout à
l'heure et loi parce que je crois qu'il
faudra attendre la semaine prochaine il
faudra attendre la semaine prochaine
puisque pour des raisons techniques vu
autant réduit qu'on a eus puisque la
conférence de presse était à 18 heures
on n'a pas pu réaliser le montage dans
les règles donc la semaine prochaine
vous aurez les interviews de joël
lautier d'igor nataf
commentant leur qualification et de
gilles catoire le maire de clichy avec
jean-claude - qui commenteront pourquoi
cette association arrive à s'illustrer
au niveau international à la conférence
de presse relativement réussie parce
qu'en plein olympiades puisqu'on est
devant la jeunesse de l'epic réel il y
avait quand même des journalistes du
parisien notamment de sa cité il y avait
cinq journalistes journalistes donc
c'est quand même ccsm pas quoi donc je
vais voter qui en pleine forme qui il
faut le rappeler est non seulement
qualifiée bon pour le championnat du
monde mais en plus ces seconds horn
kramnik au championnat du monde
voilà mais ce n'est pas le même
championnat du monde effectivement
puisque tu joues le champion du monde
fis des avec les 100 joueurs qui sont
susceptibles de se qualifier en revanche
il en train devenir chronique pour son
match contre garry kasparov à londres et
là on aura peut-être une surprise pour
vous je pense qu'on peut peut-être
commencer on peut en parler en fait on
est donc en négociation pour
retransmettre en intégralité le match en
vidéo notamment donc évidemment il y
aura aussi les applet habituel pour
suivre les parties mais en vidéo avec
les commentaires en direct ça sera très
probablement de langue en anglais en
français
bon c'est pas encore 100% mais on peut
dire que c'est quand même quasiment
acquis c'est bien avancé en tout cas
voilà alors 2e 2e point donc c'est une
bonne transition lettre ouverte
justement de la fille des policiers les
championnats du monde alors on
l'attendait depuis longtemps elle est
effectivement donc
bien le président donc de la fidh et a
émis une lettre aux kings art en
personne à kasparov pour essayer de le
convaincre et bien de refaire un match
entre le championnat du monde actuel de
la fidh et qu'on va connaître bientôt
et puis kasparov qui domine la scène et
chaque la scène échiquéenne depuis
maintenant plusieurs années donc une
lettre ouverte à kasparov qui a été mise
le 1er septembre on attend la réponse
maintenant jack king prévue fin
septembre le 30 je pense qu'il va
sûrement attendre leurs fans sur match
je pense qu'il va attendre la fin de sa
masse notamment et qui répondent avant
oui non mais disons que de toute façon
il est pratiquement obligé de refuser
puisque la formule du championnat du
monde est proposée va l'obliger à
rentrer donc pas forcément cette année
mais l'année suivante en début de
parcours
c'est peut-être cet accord c'est
peut-être une demain dans tout cas de
négociations donc à partir de là
peut-être ils arriveront à un accord sur
une formule qui serait mais un mixte des
deux exactement et c'est une sorte de
compromis
donc on pourra expliquer ça un peu plus
en détail peut-être la semaine prochaine
mais effectivement ça serait il y aurait
quelques modifications assez
significative du parcours tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui du championnat du
monde fim est en tout cas donc ces
notables
parce que bon
les deux les deux parties kasparov et la
fille ne se parlaient plus qu'est ce
qu'on voulait pas aller vers la fidl
inverse et est vrai aussi
ils sont rendu compte en tout cas au
moins du côté fidh et que bombay c'est
peut-être intéressant de se trouver une
solution voilà donc la fidh et tend la
main à kasparov ce que kasparov va
refuser cette main tendue
est ce que ce n'est pas une mais
empoisonnée a priori moi je ne vois mal
je vois mal kasparov accepté dans la
mesure où il est très bien où il est
c'est à dire tout seul les champions du
monde à tester donc a priori garica
sport va rester dans cette situation
puisque personne ne remet en doute le
fait qu'il soit numéro un mondial qu'en
ce moment là riverains effectivement et
leurs problèmes ont besoin d'une
légitimité supplémentaire mais pour
l'instant il en a pas besoin il à 100
points d'avancé sur ses poursuivants 100
points et l'aude avance donc kasparov au
dessus du paquet pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
iraient voir le peuple simplement
quelque chose à discuter en tout cas je
pense qu'on y verra plus clair après
mais je pense même au delà des deux
championnats du monde parce qu'il faut
rappeler quand même
kasparov kramnik octobre du 8 octobre au
4 novembre donc ça ça va être le gros
moments chauds du mois d'octobre
on peut regretter d'ailleurs eloi qu'il
y ait un pendant cette ce match là
d'autres événements importants et le cap
d'agde qui va avoir lieu il ya ba
croquis rencontre short en fait c'est le
calendrier qui veut ça et puis après le
championnat du monde fim et qui enchaîne
puisque donc s'il va se dérouler
novembre décembre n'ont peut-être faudra
attendre à la fin de ces deux
championnats il y aura également les
olympiades d'échecs qui commence je
crois ouais si je ne dis pas de bêtises
fin octobre oui le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que cet été aurait été
particulièrement chargée en événements
importants
je ne me rappelle pas avoir vécu une
telle saison oui mais je crois que
l'arrêt puis la fin de l'année s'annonce
donc au moins au moins aussi forte
assez assez diabolique voilà je crois
qu'on va passer tout de suite maintenant
notre deuxième partie la plus importante
de cette émission c dans parti commenté
d'aujourd'hui la partie barque par care
lautié
voilà donc partie de la semaine par care
lautier donc par care anglais contre
l'hôte évidemment c'est notre numéro un
national et loi c'était un match
important du zonage crois que c'était
une des parties fin je suit après que
l'outil est perdu il me semble alors
ouais c'est non je ne pense pas
puisqu'il était déjà en tête largement
vont signer deux des trois dernières
places est une des dernières rondes
c'est sûr de toute façon alors en
adjonction à cette partie il y aura dans
un autre fichier vidéo rapidement donc
là d'un courant de la semaine prochaine
la partie commentée par joël lautier lui
même puisqu'on a récupéré ses analyses
au club de clichy donc vous aurez ça un
petit supplément un petit fichier vidéo
supplémentaire qui doit durer une
dizaine de minutes le commentaire de
cette partie par claude authier qui
explique tous les moments importants et
la façon dont il a vécu cette partie
nous on va vous l'expliquer avec les
moyens qu'on a c'est à dire ceux qui
sont à notre disposition et donc c'est
une très belle partie en tout cas une
très belle domination de lautier avec
les pièces noires avec les pièces noires
et faut noter donc c'est une victoire il
est noir alors il faut noter que dans
ces open puisque les axemen open il est
très important y compris avec les noirs
d'essayer de gagner puisque il faut
prendre des risques sinon on passe pas
on n'est pas dans les six premiers c'est
dire que joël dans cette partie pouvait
faire nul c'était pas un drame pour la
gestion de son tournoi
mais comme on va le voir c'est à dire
qu'au début de la partie n'était pas du
tout opposé à faire nul mais très vite
et s'est retrouvé en situation de jouer
pour le gain est là il a commencé à la
jouer en fait tout simplement il n'a
plus voulu faire mieux alors voilà on
démarre donc c'est parti entre parker et
l autre alors voilà non on va faire
comme ça voilà donc d4 choisi car il ya
6 c'est qu'a donc du début classique 1
toujours pareil lutte pour le centre
avec les pions hélas après fou des
quatre ans rentre donc dans une dans une
défense nous avait jean david lynch the
beach alors évidemment on va rappeler
une fois de plus qu'elle est l'idée de
ce coup fourré 4c de plouay donc le
calice et 3 qui est ici tout ça pour
lutter pour les cas central les deux
cases éclairé en verre ici qui sont les
cases e4 et des cinq donc ici
normalement on joue des mots ces deux ou
à trois c'est les coupes principaux mais
foucher sein qui a été choisi par parker
c'est un coup un peu atypique mais qui
quand même
à ces avantages qui correspond à la
quelque part la logique de la partie
d'après ce que je peux en comprendre
puisque le fou en fait de cases noires
en b 4 qui cloue le cavalier sur le roi
permet aux noirs de contrôler les cases
des cinq es14 et donc en fait le fou de
cases blanches qui vient de jouer parker
est justement s'oppose à cette stratégie
puisque il cloue lui même le cavalier
noir qui faisait pression sur ces deux
cases tout à fait c'est un coup assez
logique pour la lutte centrale par
contre sortir le fossé entre auto alors
là je m'adresse à tous les internautes
pour toutes les positions
c'est un inconvénient majeur c'est que
ça affaiblit le pion b2 qui est ici est
également toutes les cases noires autour
du roi blanc côté dames vous pouvez
revoir la phrase si vous voulez ça fait
dix toutes les casses noirs les blancs
côté dames c'est ce qu'on va voir tout
de suite avec la réponse de joël lautier
qui tout de suite jousse et 7 6 5
ce qui libère donc la dame des mythes
pour venir éventuellement à 5
donc pour attaquer les cases noires
courrier en même temps ça fait pression
sur les quinze mois et en même temps ça
fait pression sur les cases were c'est à
dire que là les noirs tout de suite
s'attaque ne change de change d'objectif
et ne joue plus pour les cases blanches
mais pour les cases noires puisque le
phocéen est sortie probable entre auto
ici les blancs ferme le centre double
coupe des quatre des cinq on joue des
six et là ça ressemble un peu à la snake
benoni alors en ouverture très peu connu
c'est nike snake l'adena nice nice
belhani du serpent c'est une bonne année
on met pas le fou angers7
ce qui est pourtant le principe de
l'anonyme et on garde la structure avec
les pions des six essais 5 et le fou
n'est pas sur la grande diagonale mais
est passé en d4
alors que dans la fameuse astag benoni
le fou fait un parcours étonnant il
passe par sept des huit et à 5 pour
venir s'échanger compliqué ces trois
donc ici on peut considérer que les
noirs ont plusieurs tonneaux plusieurs
stands avance dans une sorte de snipe
benoni donc ici déjà gain de temps pour
joël lautier les blagues et les
blanchons un plan ambitieux bijoux f2 f3
donc là clairement ils ont déjà inversé
les rôles mais les blagues lutte
vraiment pour les cases blanches avec ce
coup notamment et puis avec les
précédents du noir quand les noirs de
france occasion vous inversez les rôles
habituels
ils ont inversé leur habituel disons que
maintenant on est plutôt dans une
logique de combat centrale puisque la
situation centre est assez à peu près
décidé les blancs vont jouer eux deux
quatre c'est sûr c'est à dire qu'ils
vont tenir le pion des 5 enfin ils vont
tenir une structure de psion
dans ce style une structure de bilan
très solide donc l'enjeu pour les noirs
maintenant c'est plus de faire un jeu de
pièces entre ses pions mais plutôt de
faire un job pions puisqu'on ne peut pas
attaquer des pions qui se tiennent les
uns des autres avec des pièces il faut
donc trouver un plan de pions voilà le
fameux alors ici joël lautier pose la
question aux fous si c'est toujours bon
à faire est ce que tu t'es charge ou
est-ce que tu recules voilà s'il faut
parents h4 il ne pourra plus revenir en
d2 ça a l'air idiot mais c'est très
important et s'il faut revient en d2 il
ne peut plus le cavalier f6 eggler a
perdu un temps sur mantes donc tout à
des tout à des inconvénients partir
décide de revenir en d2 alors surtout h
théâtre
je vous invite à voir la vidéo où joël
lautier commentera la partie c'est très
bien expliqué joël lautier dit qu'il
suffisait doué normal après forte 4 de
chouette petit roquet et b17 comprend
des 5 kg au cours des 5 avec une super
snake benoni dans ce genre de position
un petit rock côté noir ne serait pas
dangereux avec un affaiblissement comme
h6 les blancs n'ont pas encore décidé de
quel côté allait ok c'est pas un peu
dangereux de se mettre un petit peu sous
le feu d'une avalanche de pions alors ça
tue en fait on parle du coup h61 lui qui
est probablement un affaiblissement
c'est vrai qu'en cas de g4 h4 les blancs
ont tout de suite une rupture avec le
coude g4 g5
mais pour l'instant c'est pas du tout à
l'ordre du jour puisque on sait bien que
avant d'attaquer
il faut quand même penser à sortir ses
pièces et puis il faut aussi que le roi
est effectivement rockets alors pour
l'instant les noirs sont en avance de
développement puisque c'est à eux de
jouer
les blancs n'ont pas encore sorti donc
ni le fouet fin ni le canadien est pour
l'instant ces pièces ne peuvent pas
sortir il faudra encore jouer un coup de
pions fois encore je le perds 2 sortir
la dame et rauque et donc il ya beaucoup
de temps à venir avant qu'on ait le
temps de commencer cette attaque dirigée
contre le coup h6 est effectivement ici
ça ne risque rien puisque les noirs ont
quand même des choses à faire
alors donc tu reprends des cinq choisi
en échange au centre ça permet de
libérer le pouce et 8 notamment
éventuellement mais il avait du mal à
sortir sauf nous puisque les pions
blancs contre le bien les cases blanches
oui tout à fait petit rock petit rock
ici alors les blancs là n'ont pas le
choix ils doivent jouer 2,4 sinon ça
serait une renonce mans tout simplement
et là joël lautier donc ça y est
commence le plan pions c'est à dire que
là on peut plus rien faire avec les
pièces on peut plus attaquer ses pions
blancs qui
kyi dont la base commence âges et de
tous les pions se tiennent les uns les
autres
donc ici il faut faire une rupture avec
des pions c'est ce que fait déjà le
titre joue cavalier h5 mais alors là
donc ils rejouent devront jouer une
pièce qui a déjà été développé
on peut se poser la question pourquoi
ils jouent pas un coup comme aux
cavaliers b17 calais arnaud développer
une pièce est justement la réponse c'est
ça c'est que qu'a et b17 maintenant de
développer les pièces ça n'a plus
vraiment de sens il faut faire une
rupture de pions il faut pas laisser aux
blancs le temps de se développer puisque
si les blancs sorte les pièces sur le
long terme leur avantage des spas seul à
parler ils ont plus d'espacé ici avec
les pions commises à 10 ans une majorité
centrale majorité centrale ça c'est des
avantages sur le long terme
pour l'instant ils sont pas encore
sortis leurs pièces et le roi reste au
centre cavaliers h5 a effectivement la
halle avantage supplémentaire de toute
fuite fin de notre direct d'un mach 4
échecs qui des regrets le roi blanc oui
puisque ce rejet de g3 évidemment
cavaliers h5 trempions g3 oui et si les
bleus reprennent ils perdent la tourache
un hyper la twh donc ici ça oblige les
blancs a joué son coup qu'avaient les g2
et g2 puisque maintenant sort d'un match
car on jouera le coup g2 g3
le problème de ce coin de keolis chez
eux deux c'est que maintenant le faux f1
il sort plus tout simplement on aura du
mal à sortir d'avoir du mal à sortir
alors là ça fait un peu penser à des
variantes ces niches de l'est indienne
normalement les blancs prennent leur
temps pendant très longtemps les noirs
n'ont pas trop de rupture de pions et
après ils se replacent il joue qu'à
laisser un ils sortent le fou ils
reviennent avec le cabinet en b3 ou eux
deux et il arrive finalement à faire le
petit rock mais ici c'est pas du tout
pareil puisque les noirs sont très en
avance et joue directement le coup et
sept f5 donc la pression on peut montrer
peut-être une tension dans lequel des
noirs sur le pion aux quatre skippers va
permettre au noir d'avoir deux colonnes
pour leur tour une colonne ouverte de la
couronne f
s'il ya un échange et éventuellement la
colonne 1,8 jusqu'à quatre semi ouverte
puisque m pions pour lequel ils pourront
faire pression sur le pion aux quatre
échanges et alors ici vous avez un
problème de structure de pions qui est
très important c'est à dire que une fois
que les noirs ou compris c'est ce qu'on
va voir au coup d'après donc puisque les
noirs les blancs
jude mc2 cherche à mettre l'europe à
l'abri les noirs près dans le 4 et là il
ya un problème concret comment on
reprend alors il ya deux solutions soit
on reprend du cavalier soit on reprend
du pied si on reprend du cavalier le
problème c'est que l'option des 5 va
être affaibli il sera tout seul il sera
tout sauf si on reprend du pillon le
problème dont c'est la partie c'est ce
qu'on va voir la pression prendre quatre
la case aux cinq donc et pour les noirs
puisqu'on peut plus chasser un cavalier
qui s'installerait sur cette case
mais plus de deux ans pour attaquer
cette cadre alors d'habitude on dit
toujours que les noirs doivent dans un
premier temps égalisé essayer d'égaliser
une fois que la position devenu légal et
c'est de jouer aux initiatives affaiblir
le camp adverse et est-ce qu'on peut
dire déjà la cote 12e coup et bien joué
elle a réussi un tour de force un tour
de main pas possible il a pris davantage
alors maintenant ils ont peut plus
raisonner comme ça on peut plus dire que
les noirs jouent pour faire d'abord
l'égalité et ensuite gagner puisque
c'est plus du tout c'est plus du tout à
la mode 7 7 cet état d'esprit en fait ce
mode de pensée
maintenant les noirs ne joue plus pour
égaliser il joue simplement pour
compliquer la position à mort et ensuite
d'une position très compliqué peut
sortir n'importe quoi soit un avantage
blanc soit l'égalité soit un avantage
noir mais en tout cas on ne joue plus
d'abord pour faire nul et ensuite pour
gagner maintenant on joue directement
pour mettre le bordel sur l'échiquier
oui c'est l'école moderne c'est tout à
fait ça donc garry kasparov qui
évidemment est le plus grand défenseur
de cette théorie comme il dit moi je
suis prêt à jouer n'importe quelle
position
si toutes les suites de mon adversaire
perdent et que s'ils jouent quatre fois
le meilleur coup de suite il va gagner
d'accord mais il les trouvera jamais que
kasparov en fait est un joueur de poker
cette semaine pas un joueur scientifique
c'est un joueur de poker comme l'as
kairn com lascars qui était très
pratique et bien kasparov dit voilà je
peux jouer quelque chose au perdant je
sais que mon adversaire trouvera pas la
solution c'est laid trop compliqué donc
je n'ai pas peur de ça va un parfait
exemple si qu'illustre ce genre de
tactique et étals il me semble
magicien de rigueur qui n'hésitait pas à
faire des sacrifices intuitif pour
prendre une initiative parfois douteuses
et ça lui réussit si bien oui au total
c'est quand même été champion du monde
mais que effectivement il jouer des
choses douteuses mais pas tant que ça
c'était quand même de la haute voltige
mais avec phil est donc maintenant qu'à
aider cette maintenance à ce style plus
puisque effectivement lequel ils peuvent
venir en 5 en étant tranquille tout à
l'heure si on les avait sortis tant
qu'ils avaient le pion f
oui s'il était venu sur cazaux siens
qu'il aurait pu être chassé par f3 f4 et
maintenant il va être tranquille en 5
alors à noter vous le remarquerez dans
la vidéo joël lautier commente le coup
f34 commettant une grosse erreur
donc il fallait reprendre selon lui du
cavalier et obtenir une position à peu
près égal mais les noirs n'avaient déjà
plus de problèmes d'ouverture donc ici à
près de 34 c'est une faute
cavalier 17 on va venir s'installer en
haut 5 et on peut noter on a oublié de
signaler que la tour et suites et
merveilleuse à la truite est extrêmement
bien placé et c'est là l'élément ll est
à une action et le énorme le pion 4 par
contre est horrible c'est un pion un
arriéré il ya une superbe casse pour les
noirs en 5
c'est vrai que pas belle à voir la
position blanche a priori elle est pas
belle à voir maintenant imaginons que
les blancs et 2 pouces c'est à dire pour
jouer h3g 4 chasser le cavalier noir de
h5 sortir ensuite leur cas liés aux deux
ans j'ai 3 donc là je peux vous montrer
un en gros l'idée des blancs dans cette
position-là leur perspective qui
pourrait les rendre mieux c'est de jouer
3 et 4 chassez le cavalier ensuite
prendre le cavalier de le mettre en g3
puis enlève 5
et là les blancs ou une position
dominante puisqu'il aurait plus d espace
quoique là sa soeur thorel
en fait à 1 dames peut-être acheter
chaque nom ah oui tout à fait dans dans
l'immédiat c'est à l'ordre du jour mais
peut-être à moyen terme c'est
envisageable
c'est à dire que les noirs doivent quand
même faire attention puisque des blancs
ont un plan les blancs ne sont pas
complètement démunis dans cette position
d'un grand roque des blancs rock déjà ça
évite d'un match là donc ça peut menacer
peut-être même tout de suite j'ai dejé 4
sa menace tout de suite j'ai 2 et 4
peut-être oui oui c'est une remarque
très justes donc car il ya cinq ans
pêche g2g 4l en plus il est très bien
passé ça libère le fou s'est vite qui
pourra éventuellement se libérer plus
tard venir ce congé théâtre soit en 17
mars et de gaz pour le fou qui sont tout
à fait et puis alors on voit on voit
qu'à des cases blanches ni côté blanc
notamment la casse et 4 où pouvaient
bondir le cavalier de 5 ça peut créer
des motifs parce que qu'il ya déjà un
fou qui traîne un barrage alors plus un
cavalier ça peut créer des petits motifs
c'est simplement la menace directe c'est
de jouer qui avait laissé quatre puisque
le fou des deux ne peut pas repartir au
voilà je vous le montre tout de suite
s'il repart en un lecavalier vient de
ces cas 33 effectuant une fourche est
d'avis qu'on fait là mais tour qu'avait
laissé 4 échangerait un un fou pour un
cavalier c'est à dire qu'on prendrait le
fou de cases noirs des blancs et se fout
là est très très important dans cette
position puisque c'est un des défenseurs
de la case aux 5 donc effectivement ici
la bonnasse c'est qu'avec ses 4 et
cavaliers profond menace positionnelle
roi béhanzin aménageant une case de
fuite pour le fou des deux cas c'est un
fou 17 juin lautié prépare la tacc il
veut jouer mais c'est un cas 5-fu prend
ses 3 et b4 c'est un coup de préparation
un coup de dé veloppement effectivement
on dit souvent qu'il faut lier les tours
donc là ça va être ça la torah y viens
de voir on a vraiment l'impression que
ça peut venir de partout parce que si si
le fou qui est en d2 est attaqué par le
cavalier il ya peut-être des cases qui
vont se libérer pour la tour descendre
sur la tf de passe dans la calèche de
paris alors il faut absolument que les
blancs réagissent et face la contre
attaque on avait dit tout à l'heure donc
attaque avec leurs deux pions ici contre
le roi noir une faux il faut qu'ils
créent du contenu de ce côté là sinon on
serait tous fait ils ont rien à opposer
du côté dames c'est clair c'est clair
ici côté dames s'est perdue puisque les
noirs ont trois pions contre 2 et en
plus ça effectivement il ya le roi blanc
alors qu'il a pas le renoir
donc si les noirs envoie une marée de
pions si on leur laisse 58
ils vont faire une
gagnante et victorieuse donc les blancs
n'ont pas de nom pas d'autre choix dans
cette position que de contre attaquer et
c'est évidemment ce qu'il faut avec le
coup 15 h 3 voilà donc ici si les 6 et
aux blancs de jouer après le coup j'ai
quatre cavaliers bouge et cavalier e 2
angers 3 pour le repositionner f5
lieblien serait pas plus mal
les blancs commencerait à obtenir en
tout cas des chances de contre je ne
serai pas forcément plus mal puisque
leur attaque arrive assez vite quand
même donc ici évidemment joël lautier
l'empêchent en jouant cavalier c4 alors
ça n'empêche puisque ces attaques le
food est de tout simplement qu'une pièce
clé de la position blanche
le four une toile donc repartir
maintenant qu'il n'est plus en d2 ça
permet au noir de jouer ce coup tous
rêvent 2 puisque ligne à plus de fous
des deux ans le 1 qui cherche la tour
voilà donc évidemment beaucoup de choses
que je vous dis là sont reprises des
commentaires de lautier c'est quand même
plus facile
et en plus ça le mérite d'être problème
en plus juste alors à noter quand même
cette tour est très embêtante pour les
blancs puisque ça cloue le cavalier à
deux donc sa menace et si on ne prend
par exemple du fou en c3 maintenant on
peut plus reprendre du cavalier sa
menace aussi des coups comme cavalier g3
éventuellement kg le kg 3 qui attaquent
la tourache 1 et le faisan et le fouet
puisque effectivement on sait que
prendre un fou c'est quand même une
bonne chose toujours moi évidemment les
noirs là ils ont des plans qui ne se
comptent plus de 9 6 tours à suite pour
passer sur la colonne est donc c'est à
dire sur ce volet sur le lit des blancs
g2g 4 maintenant le cavalier peut venir
effectivement sur le cac ce g3 oui on
est tout à fait donc ici pas de g4 le
gros problème des blancs dans cette
position c'est toujours ce cavalier en
deux qui ne bouge pas qui donc
enfin je vais le montrer puisque c'est
le camion aux deux qui bloquent
complètement le froid faim le froid faim
ne peut pas passer plus loin et du coup
ça bloque aussi la tourache 1 et ça
bloque la tourache ça bloque
complètement le développement des blancs
dam des trois attaques lecavalier donc
double idée ça tacle kbc 4 et ça pour
contrôler la case g3 wii qui fait que ça
des cookies rio devait également et ça
découle clavier 2 donc sa manager de g4
d'accord donc attaque lecavalier 6 4
kadio 5 en fait là le cavalier a rempli
son office
il était là pour perturber le fou
le fou de cases blanches de canmore par
nombre des blancs qui est venu se mettre
en séance et 1
maintenant il peut repartir sur sa case
casse génial en et cinq sur sa très
belle occasion c'est tout à fait donc ça
y est dames eu trois attaques la tour
eiffe deux attaques la tour est ici la
faute de joel noter qu'ils déclarent
qu'ils auraient pu gagner plus
facilement s'ils avaient joué au lieu de
la fuite qu'il a joué le ku'damm f6
alors il est question qu'on se pose on
trouve souvent envie de mettre la dame
plutôt sur cette case oui ce qu'on peut
dire que l'autre tour pour revenir en
fuite la photo pour autant la suite mais
c'est chaud par contre parce que là il
ya un cavalier qui va être un peu en
l'air dans lequel ils font h5
voilà ça y est j'ai de g4 qui menace le
cavalier h5 ne pourra plus revenir sur
la kdf 6 donc sur dame f6 on va regarder
brièvement donc on va indiquer cette
vente ça n'a pas été jouée par choix de
lautier donc jouer lautier dit qu'il
aurait dû jouer ça ici il ya le coup
j'ai dauger quatre et maintenant ça
devient extrêmement chaud après donc
variant donné par joël lautier puisque
là c'est très très compliqué qui avait
laissé quatre dames détroit et alors là
je crois qu'il a parlé du coup foot
français 3 non je ne sais plus
exactement de quoi il a parlé donc
effectivement c'était très compliqué il
a mis du temps à s'en rappeler cheikh
c'était fou prend ces trois faux procès
3 et surtout on prend ces trois fous des
5 c'était des variantes comme ça il
exactement ça et le je pense que sur fou
prend ces trois il conseillé d'ailleurs
j'ai prend le cavalier en h5 d'accord ou
alors c'était peut-être ça on ne je ne
me rappelle pas exactement le fait est
que c'est dans la vidéo annexes déjà
donc pas de problème est par contre
damas trois dames et fuites le coup jose
par joël qui al'avantage effectivement
de laisser libre cette case f6 pour le
cavalier donc dans les variantes qui
suivrait à projets 4 donc ça c'est très
intéressant c'est un moment où donc on
vous conseille bien de regarder cette
interview de joël lautier donc on vous
passera pour la semaine prochaine on la
passera soit dans l'émission soit comme
tu dis éventuellement un vidéo associée
cette émission en plus et dans laquelle
jour elle explique notamment qu'il
aurait pu jouer dans m6 c'est d'ailleurs
une explication qui dépasse le
lui-même puisqu'il en fait il expliqué
très bien que dans cette partie là vont
ils jouaient pas forcément pour le gain
une nulle l'arrangé l'arrangé presque
elle se disant elle se placer dans une
logique donc dans la logique de son
parcours
je pense qu'un joueur comme jouer le
lotier doit gérer son tournoi et parfois
faire des nuls
surtout que là il a des noirs et donc je
pense qu'il aurait pas été un certain
moment de la partie contre de faire une
nulle et puis le jeu a fait que l'élu
envie de gagner comme il dit c'est
dommage de faire nul dans une si belle
position
c'est vrai que les pièces noires ont
quand même l'air très très actifs alors
dames et fuite que la pâleur notre
mauvais coup quand même donc évidemment
g4 g4tv c4 alors à noter quand même qu
effectivement que par rapport à 2006 ça
empêche j'ai quatre câbles et si c'est
toujours pas possible puisque la tour f
2 sur l'emprise oui oui tout à fait bien
que c'est quand même
d'ailleurs on va voir ce qui s'est passé
laquelle ces quatre attaques la dame
la dame revient des trois attaques de
pièces à table quand même le cavaly c4
et le quadrillage quelqu'un achète
toujours attaquer voilà donc ici une
seule solution pour joël cavalli revient
aux 5
donc on revient ouais les blancs peuvent
s'en aller mais c'est pas très bon
puisque s'ils sont s'ils s'en vont en d2
où ces deux car ils jetteront un oeil
aux racailles g3 donc ils doivent
revenir en 3 nous qui si joël est sûr
qu'il annule en poche puisqu'il suffit
de jouer qui s'éclate et camillo 5 mai
donc là il se pose la question est ce
que je les jouais ce que je la joue pas
et il finit par jouer france et 3 pour
le sco vent fou prince étrange alors là
on se demande pourquoi les blancs ou
tout simplement ne prendrai pas me
lecavalier et servir de libérer toutes
les pièces alors tout à fait sûre
qu'elle va dépenser 3 c'est une variante
a mentionné puisque là on a l'impression
maintenant que le cavalier sortie de sa
mauvaise case le fouet fin va pouvoir
bouger mais de l'autre côté ça contrôle
- les cases f4 et g3 alors peut-être les
mineurs peuvent en profiter
il est si je pense qu'il y a tous rêvent
323 la dame de bouger peut-être d'en
manger un peut-être d'en manger un oui
pour tâcher cavani effectivement j'ai 3
mais bon ça ça ne m'empêche pas vraiment
et ici à 1000 f 4k blessé trois ans que
les femmes aussi les trois noms 6,6 kg 3
et le est probablement le coût attendu
ici dans cette position qui a l'air de
poser de gros problèmes en tout cas aux
blancs du gros problème a fait tout ce
jeu sur la colonne f
c'est à dire qu'en fait après faut
penser 3 si lecavalier reprend
effectivement le cas ça permet aux
cavaliers noirs de venir s'accrocher sur
les cases f4 ou g3 et ça c'est un gros
problème c'est un gros problème en fait
pour les blancs qui ne peuvent pas
tolérer quelque chose comme ça et donc
sur foot français 3 donc des princes et
rois ce n'est pas en ballon du tout
dépensé 3 ou s'affaiblit le roi puis
mais maintenant il est encore kelis et 4
dames d3 et d5 peut-être oui qui peut
venir un thème qui peut arriver donc ici
tu reprends h5 contraint et forcé mais
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle puisque ça enlève un
pur de l'attak parce qu'il va plus
pouvoir jouer g4 g5
oui on contrôle - lacazette 5 aussi donc
le cabillaud ne pourra pas sauter sur la
canette c'est donc ça fait bien un petit
peu c'est là c'est une faillite en fait
pour le plan blanc et ont l'impression
que les mains peuvent plus attaquer le
roi le roi noir ou très difficilement
alors que maintenant les noirs le champ
libre du côté dames
bon il ya un problème énorme aussi pour
les dons maintenant c'est que toutes les
finales sont complètement perdante
pourquoi justement parce que y'a le pion
à je crois qui est en prise par le fou
le pion à stein qui pourra jamais
défendu l'option rocade qui est faible
donc la seule chance des blancs dans
cette position c'est de faire une taille
de maths parce que si les noirs échange
les dames dont il ya plus d attaques de
mattia plus aucune chance pour les
blancs les pions sont trop faibles
donc ça c'est un prochain gros problème
en fait pour pour les blancs qui vont
être obligés maintenant par tous les
moyens de chercher à attaquer donc
parker joue à 5 par dans l'autre joël
joël jutge 9 x 5 et l'a donc le coup
logique tour g1
on cherche absolument à augmenter une
attaque contre le roi noir puisque une
menace directe images du direct d'impro
h6 d'un proche disparaît par joël
lautier rouages 7 est maintenant donc
tout ça c'est très logique
maintenant les blancs joue cavalier f4
coûts qui n'aurait pas été possible si
la dame noire avait été en effet 6 c'est
là qu'on voit la différence en fait
c'est assez subtil
si la dame n'aura été en effet si sur
les deux est fluide donc là c'est un
choix qu'il fallait faire 5 ou avant
c'est pas évident et bien il y aurait
pas eu la réponse blanche pour y avait
des f4 puisqu'après tour f3 et bien la
dame blanche aurait obligé de partir et
on aurait pu le qualifie quatre là la
dame est dans la fuite et ça change tout
donc ça attaque la toile de 11 jeux tout
h 30 et maintenant donc la dame blanche
n'est pas obligé de boucher puisqu'elle
n'aurait pas de casse de voitures point
f4
il ya ce coup intermédiaire kg 6 quelle
justice qui a contre attaque sur la
noire avec échec
voilà femme qui menacent cavaliers prend
la fuite
échec au roi faudrait comparer les
chèques et ensuite on récupérera toro 3
s'il avait pris la dame blanche par le
phocéen donc le coup de jouer les logis
d'un même si son expression quand même
que ce cavalier blanc est bien placé en
g 6 1 le cavalier blanc est
effectivement bien placé on ne peut pas
dire le contraire
d'un autre côté bon les pièces noires
sont quand même pas mal non plus oui
pièce la dame de la main deux tours f2
attaque adams est un test d'âmes aux
trois tours est roi pourquoi faire une
répétition du coup alors il ya 2 il ya
deux avantages à faire une répétition de
coûts le premier s'est déjà on est sûr
qu'on peut faire nul donc effectivement
qu est ce qu on voit que notre
adversaire n'a pas le choix on sait
qu'on a une sécurité on a la garantie
qu'on peut faire mieux
l'autre avantage est plus subtil et plus
pervers c'est qu'on gagne du temps ces
terres qu'on gagne des coûts et donc il
ya des notes on doit jouer 40 coups en
deux heures si on commence à être un peu
pressés à la pendule ce qui était le cas
de joël dans cette position est bien là
ça fait beaucoup de moi à jouer ça me
vient d'achever tous rêvent deux étoiles
3 le 40e ou n'est plus court 38e alors
après qu'on a rappelé qu aux échecs la
partie nulle si on retrouve trois fois
la même position et donc on a droit de
répéter une position de deux fois
c'était bobby fischer qui est son époque
avait dit ne faut jamais raté une
occasion de répéter les coups mais c'est
la mythique bobby fischer oui parce que
kasparov a une autre explication sur la
pétition coup il dit ça fait croire à
mon adversaire qui va peut-être pouvoir
faire nul facilement donc ils commencent
à se relâcher un petit peu et là où
c'est encore plus vicieux et au lycée
donc c'est effectivement chacun ses
techniques dame de damas deux
conseillers je le tiens à répéter les
coups les blancs pensent qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire nul donc là si les noirs
refonte oref 2 on va se retrouver en
position de ne pas encore donc pas
encore mais ces faits d'armes de damas
trois tours f3 là cette fois c'est
vraiment nous voilà c'est parce que
l'adversaire peut demander peut demander
l'annulation joué son coup en france la
série d'arbitrages qui n'ont aucun
intérêt donc les noirs ici décide de la
jouer une fois de plus 6 a de l'intérêt
faut pas dire que ça pas l'intérêt c'est
très intéressant
c'est donc très intéressant être assez
précis parce que sinon on peut rater des
occasions canton comme ça se présente et
de nous
donc expliquer la règle sinon voilà
c'est ce que c'est très important a
largement expliqué voilà alors quand
vous allez répéter votre cou pour la
troupe vous aller répéter la même
position pour la troisième fois il faut
pas jouer le coup il faut pas jouer le
coup avant de jouer le coup vous dites à
votre adversaire nul
si votre adversaire dit non je la joue
vous appelez un arbitre
larbitre arrive vous dit à l'arbitré je
vais jouer ce coup vous le notez sur
votre feuille vous joué le coup
vous arrêtez la pendule vous fait
constater à larbi qui est trois fois la
même position larbi dida corps
l'adversaire est donc obligé de signer
la feuille deux parties nulles
et voilà vous les faits dans les règles
voit l'annoncé on peut noter à mais
c'est très très important
c'est comme au football et le hors jeu
pour savoir pourquoi il a revu là c'est
pareil tout à fait voilà les revoilà
donc tour vite alors ça c'est
intéressant puisque les noirs active la
dernière pièce qui jouait pas vraiment
c'est la torah 8 qui maintenant est très
bien placé sur cette colonne eux et
cette pression et s'est fait pression
sur le pion aux quatre attaques la dame
parfois new x par rayons x tacle à damas
quelque époque tour pronostique pour
prendre 5 donc des pièces noires très
active on voit que les blancs n'ont
toujours pas réussi à sortir leurs
souhaits fin où ça s'est quand même
c'est ennuyeux pour g6 activités non je
joue simplement damas fuite enfin joël
lautier tout simplement détruites et ici
les blancs je pense joue la faute
décisives ou d'objets 2 peut-être qu'il
aurait été préférable de le fou j'ai
deux mais en tout cas après d'alger 2 il
se lance dans une combinaison qui ne
marche pas du tout et on va voir
pourquoi
mais la position est déjà très difficile
pour les blancs après il faut g2 il y
avait peut-être tour f2 qui pouvaient
tempêtant pour les blancs tous rêvent de
la dame bouge
peut-être que les blancs ont quelques
espoirs ton rêve devient presque 8
probablement la tour est obligé de jouer
au foot orange et si ses lampions là on
prend un virage 5
oui ça a l'air d'être terminée c'est une
des possibilités en tout cas ici les
blancs jouent leur va-tout
il joue d'alger 2 ça perd de manière
forcée
joël lautier ici calcul très précisément
très précisément il calcule tout
jusqu'au bout
effectivement on va voir qu'il était
impitoyable au prince trois moments
comme ça donc ça laisse pas les blancs
n'ont pas trop le choix là là les bleus
n'ont pas le choix s'ils bougent c'est
tout simplement perdants on prend le
frais fin on échange tout la finale est
finie on prend le point fr et le pion
aux cinq puisque plancher étant prises
par la tour aux singles
faire deux points de plus au nord au
passage échanger toutes les pièces donc
ce sera tout simplement terminer tour
qui ont acheté ces chèques ça c'est la
combinaison des blancs donc c'est
intéressant
alors ici il ya une photo ne pas faire
c'est roy contout évidemment si on
reprend tour il ya d'alger six échecs et
mat voilà reprend tour on voit que la
dame arrive et assène le fameux baiser
de la main les éléments activement tout
à fait comme on dit donc dans les airs
grâce à leroy
voilà je prends toujours beaucoup plus
fort puisque maintenant donc d'alger 6
quand même rouach fuite alors ici sur
fou prend 1,6 à le roi refuse le baiser
surtout pour un chiffre très important
ça a l'air très fort puisque la dame a
pas trop de cases aussi à la casse g8
mais il ya mieux il ya le coup tours f6
si je ne dis pas de bêtises on peut
prendre la dame je dis peut-être une
bêtise
oui j'ai dit une erreur effectivement
essayé le ku'damm f6 voilà madame fils
qui échangent adam damev si ce qui est
beaucoup plus fort puisque maintenant
sur fou prend un trou d'homme projet 6
donc faut point je crois c'est ce coup
là on joue dame prend dame suivie de
tourcoing fou avec une tour de plus et
sur d'un programme c'est à dire là c'est
les blancs qui jouait d'un programme on
jouerait tout simplement et bientôt
reprendre pour prendre un attaquant la
fois ci attend le faux justice donc on
les restants avec l'appui de mes
batailles également avec une tour de
plus donc ici ce n'est pas une option de
jouer faut pour acheter les blancs
jouent donc d'abord fou pour un f3
pourquoi je crois maintenant fous pour
acheter une franchise donc ça a l'air
quand même toujours un peu forte mais
faut rappeler que les blancs quand même
une tour de moins les blancs les plombs
ont une tour de - effectivement
donc le répète mais par contre c'est
quand même dangereux y a plus la casaque
6 pour la dame
il ya donc plus qu'une case c'est la
casse j'ai vite pour parer le matin et à
l'être il faut faire attention
dames j'évite d'un même si ces chèques
dont classer ces principes quand même
les normes donc un seul coup ses rouages
set et là il ya plus des chèques pour
les blancs pour les we les blancs non
plus des chèques et reste avec une tour
de moins c'est donc une position qui est
désespérée il faut bien le faut bien le
dire une tour de moins c'est s'est
perdue il ya plus d'échecs
donc bon on essaie quand même quelque
chose il faut être quatre une petite
menace de maths dans machisme hâte d'un
machisme at faire attention sur le thème
il en est le maître des épaulettes
malgré cette pause n peut voir plusieurs
tableaux de magritte 2000 épaules c'est
cette semaine folle sermat d'une demi et
paulette voilà parce que quand on met la
dame comme ça devant le roi faut que la
case cette case ci soient occupés par
une caisse éventuellement l'autre car on
voit pas sur l'échiquier
mais si on imagine ans le roi une
colonne à gauche
il faudrait qu'une autre pièce occupée à
cases pour qu'on ait les deux épaules
est il s'agit ici de la case imite voilà
la casse
8 qui n'existe pas qui n'existe pas donc
menace un match des demi et paulette
voilà paré par joël lautier mais qui
part qui fait d'une pierre deux coups
puis voilà tour été attaqué aussi voilà
ils menacent ils menaçaient faut prendre
tout rossi dont claire la tour vient
protéger la cage à 6 en même temps
qu'elle s'enlève de la prise du fou
l'homme prend des six les blancs
maintenant jouent pour leur d'options
passé lié mais on va voir que ce n'est
pas suffisant puisque joël lautier dans
cette position je tout rachat va
échanger la dernière tour le dernier
défenseur du roi blanc cette fois ci
c'est le roi blanc qui se retrouve sous
le feu des pièces et demie et on voit
que là ça va pas faire de cadeau puisque
à la dame qui varient venger d'eux les
tours qui vont s'échanger le roi blanc
va se retrouver complètement ivre ce
rallye va se faire mater donc sfr
réseauter réseauter comme on dit dans le
jargon
voilà bah c'est surprenant qu'il ait
perdu aussi vite après sa combinaison en
fait est-ce qu'il a mal calculé ou
est-ce que vous allez y alliez solution
il ya deux solutions soit il a mal
calculé soit l'autre chose c'est qu'ils
se dit bon là y'a plus rien toute façon
j'ai pas j'arrive pas à trouver comment
je peux m'en sortir dans cette variante
mais il ya quelques échecs et j'ai
peut-être des petites chances donc entre
quelque chose il y aura des chances de
faire une force et une position que je
vais souffrir pendant vingt coups contre
lautier qui va pas me rater je choisi de
jouer
le joker comme on dit souvent aux échecs
il vaut mieux une fin sans souffrance qu
une souffrance sans fin
oui tout à fait oui tiens donc voilà
partis donc évidemment que vous on vous
invite à regarder la vidéo annexes ça
sera moins joli que l'échiquier ici mais
ça sera plus précis puisque c'est joël
lautier qui fait des commentaires
voilà donc avec joie le dit lui-même
dans les commentaires donc on peut on
attendre tous cette vidéo où j'espère
que on va pouvoir effectivement la
mettre en ligne en ligne comme il faut
voilà donc très jolie partie donc à
noter que c'était l'avant dernière
victoire de joëlle thouvenin ce tournoi
elle a gagné ensuite je suis plus
content qu'ils l'avant dernière il a
fait nul contre levante délit tranquille
à la dernière ronde il assuré voilà il
assuré il gagne le tournoi avec un demi
point avance ou 1.128 progrès de madame
points il faut se calmer
malgré une défaite donc contre bois
défaite contre reste en dehors commenté
la semaine dernière dans des gonades
effectivement vous pouvez vous revenir
sur les archives comme dit fort
justement joël lors de la conférence de
presse lors de l'interview sa défaite
avec beauvais en fête a été salvatrice
pour lui ça lui a donné un bon coup de
fouet parce que dans le tournoi après
les victoires qu'ils avaient enchaîné en
début de camp début de ce tournoi
il s'était quelque peu relâchée avec
quelques nuls et puis la grande claque
bauer est arrivé et la bombe à joël
s'est ressaisi et puis a embrayé
derrière
de folie et finalement je termine le
tournoi premiers ce qui n'aurait
peut-être pas été le cas s'il avait fait
nul contre l'ol qui sait - et peut-être
peut-être il aurait pu l'interview c'est
pour la semaine prochaine pour la
semaine prochaine voilà donc on va
passer maintenant une troisième partie
il ya beaucoup de news à voir cette
semaine
voilà les les news voilà de cette
semaine alors nicolas notamment
un festival miguel nash d'or en
argentine ont rappelé qu'ils aient
miguel hnatow donc meegan l'âge d'or
c'est une grande figure donc du jeu
d'échecs miliana d'or ccc l'inventeur de
la fameuse variante de la sicilienne
nage dorff qui aujourd'hui est encore
pratiquée au plus haut niveau et je
crois qu'elle est pratiquée me
semble-t-il par éloi et également oui
tout à fait je suis un
fervent défenseur de cette défense donc
mis des flyers des dépenses majorque est
une figure emblématique des échecs donc
en espagne et c'est l'argentine en
argentine pardon en argentine est très
précis facile et non mais alors c'est
quand même régulièrement qu on a déjà
des tournois en amérique du sud on a
parlé déjà du mémorial capablanca
qu'elle lui à cuba on avait parlé
l'année dernière avec la participation
d' etienne bacrot d'ailleurs il ya deux
ans je sais plus exactement mais il
avait joué le mémorial capablanca l'île
à la havane où il son autre nom mais il
se rappelle pas une once caldas aussi
morales figurent des échecs
sud-américaine qu'il est les champions
du monde
le mémorial rubinstein également il n'y
a pas très longtemps voilà il ya eu
aussi le tournoi de au mexique qui a eu
lieu avec shirov notamment qui a joué à
mérida la mairie ainsi qu'en juin donc
en amérique du sud il ya aussi des
grands tournois
un petit peu moins qu'en europe mais
régulièrement il ya quand même de très
très fortement c'est vrai alors il ya
également donc en fait on va quand même
de citer c'est le fameux memorial day
geof
voilà où la s'est imposé de jouer la
sicilienne donc puisque madoff était un
joueur de génie dans la sicilienne là il
s'agit des festivaliers le mémorial ya
quelques années où il ya eu karpov jeudi
pôle gare je crois alexei shirov tous
les joueurs s'étaient donc à donner à ce
petit jeu qui est de jouer uniquement
les céciliennes donc ouvertures forcées
eux quatre ces cinq cavaliers f3 et là
c'est une c6 des annonces tout ce qu'on
veut mais c'est une cécile ouverte il
faut jouer des de décaler sa love
quelque chose alors en regardant un
petit peu les parties de plus près je
pensais que cette règle était encore en
vigueur pour ce festival
parce qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
de vraiment très surprenant c'est que
karpov joue des sicilienne lui qui joue
d'habitude des carreaux cannes des
carreaux cannes ou des carreaux kahn est
bien là il joue des siciliens si bien
que j'aie revenir à ses premières amours
on peut que je ne la joue et voilà la
garde en plus jeunes il a joué
effectivement c'est alors est-ce que tu
as un commentaire par rapport à ça
eloi non je n'ai pas de commentaire par
rapport à ça simplement j'ai été un peu
surpris par l'image rendue par toi sur
la caméra tu avais l'air d'être au
ralenti alors donc tout à fait dupe à
fait surprenant mais alors donc
effectivement car peuvent joindre à la
sicilienne c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
on peut supposer qu'il a plus assez
d'énergie pour gagner les lainages or
l'écart accalmie dans les tarots cannes
puisque ça demande une énergie quand
même assez considérable de jouer des
positions égal tout le temps pendant 50
kw 75 70 coups jusqu'à ce que
l'adversaire craque
ouais peut-être un peu fatigant pour
karpov le fait est qu'il ya dans les
premières rondes il a joué les trois
plus faibles du tournoi
donc effectivement quand les plus
faibles ne faut pas leur donner une
opportunité d'avoir une position idéale
et pour ça la cécilienne c'est très très
fort donc tu penses qu'il garde son arme
principale lacarrau cannes pour les
joueurs
costaud j'ai du mal à imaginer que
karpov johnny sicilienne judit polgar
par exemple alors il a joué contre
gilles polgar ils ont joué une
estonienne
il a donc tout et des quatre mais la
voilà et karpov avait les blancs oui
donc on pourra pas justement c'est bon à
savoir noms et par contre il yad'autres
fort joueur par exemple à bolo gangan un
joueur sicilienne on verra si karpov lui
joue le jeu sissina je pense pas y
apporte aussi qu'un tueur sicilienne jeu
contre ces joueurs là ces écarts peuvent
a évidemment joué une carte à gagner des
parties ou kasparov d'ailleurs wilshere
poser c'est le seul joueur au monde à
posséder gros problème avec les sports
sur la cécilienne notamment sur le
nasdaq avec les variantes anglaise et
les fameuses non pas qu'ils avaient
entendu les anglais ça le fait un peu
sourire casse parce que c'est de jouer à
quatre en général c'est très difficile
pour les blancs mais par contre avec
simplement le l'attaquent bellini
rohfritsch que j'aurais fischer oui et
pourtant dans le match qui l'a opposé à
karpov et kasparov ya quelques années il
avait perdu énormément de
deux parties charte contre l'ess par
toutes les céciliennes 2
oui mais c'est parce que je sors tu
n'avais pas le niveau de jeu suffisant
pour tenir contre kasparov
mais simplement dans les ouvertures il a
obtenu des pressions extrêmement fortes
et c'est le seul au monde qui arrive à
poser des problèmes à kasparov dans
l'ouverture sur la sicile est le seul
joueur au monde
voilà alors on va rappeler donc ce
tournant a pris la route de 4 au
classement mais on retrouve au beau
logan alors bologan faut rappeler qu on
a ni interviews de boue logan qu'on
avait fait à enghien en février alors 99
pour la retrouver c'est très simple vous
allez sur le site diagonale qui dit non
à une fois comme dans le moteur de
recherche vous tapez bologan ou plus
interview par exemple et là vous arrivez
directement sur l'émission bologan et
interviewer avec un petit dessin de
logan d'ailleurs vous cliquez dessus et
là vous arrivez sur l'état football
hogan c'est très simple voilà donc d'où
l'intérêt de ce site des gones eyetv
points comme avec toute la base de
données associées alors à égalité avec
karpov
ensuite on retrouve juste derrière une
position en troisième et quatrième
position juste un demi point pôle gare
et short et ils sont suivis par ricardo
riccardi pablo argentin qui est un point
de retard par contre sur le second et
donc il y a on peut dire que les
européens ont fait le trou
alors il ya un fait marquant sur la
ronde de trois si je ne m'abuse
judit polgar avec les blancs a gagné
contre short c'était une française et
j'ai dit à gagner contre contre-indiqué
le short donc lanig elle est en train de
refaire le forcing pour revenir mais
belle performance prestation du dic en
petite correction puisque tout détail a
son importance il s'agit de nigel short
et non pas nickel alors deuxième
information importante cette semaine le
championnat du monde junior on en a
parlé la semaine dernière puisque robert
fontaine était notre invité robert qui
représente la france à ce championnat du
monde junior en tant que champion de
france junior tout simplement
oui déjà en titre et donc il ya juste eu
pour l'instant on a on ajuste les
informations pour les deux premières on
a c'est ça oui
robert dessalles l idée de la force du
temps mois déjà oui puisque il suffit de
mentionner les premiers par exemple il
ya adrian qui est en tête avec deux
points sur deux oui qui est très
prometteur qui est un des meilleurs
joueurs arménien toutes catégories qui a
pris de 2600 points elo est évidemment
un des grands favoris de cette épreuve
bon les autres joueurs sont également
très forts peut-être qu'on va les
mentionner oui bah lauria
il y avoue venco iakovenko pardon sol ac
milan alors il s'agit de drazen sollac
qui est un joueur un joueur croate de
1450 qui est un peu surprenant dans ce
tournoi puisque d'eau sur deux c'est ses
supérieurs à ce niveau qu'on attend ni
ton c'est le jeune espoir alors lui je
ne sais pas de quelle nationalité il est
mêlé extrêmement jeune il doit avoir 15
ou 16 ans donc c'est un des plus jeunes
du tournoi ou alors en tout cas ils
avaient 15-16 ans quand je les ai vus
mais en tout cas il est extrêmement fort
très très prometteur donc lui ce n'est
pas une grosse surprise
il ya aussi pérèle stein voyez alors lui
et n'est pas connu et cause il n'est
encore moins voilà avoir après on
retrouve d'autres joueurs mais il ya
retrouvé malakoff malakoff où il faut
quand même le signaler
ouais mais là comme une femme au vert
fontaine est le seul représentant
français
oui et je crois que malheureusement il a
fait un début de tournoi difficile
oui il a du jus un fort la première
ronde des perdrix faire nul contre un
peu fort à la deuxième donc ça devient
un point sur deux ce qui est pas une
c'est pas une très bonne performance
mais rien n'est perdu
le fait est que c'est difficile
d'arriver en arménie est toujours
attendre oui c'est pas facile parce que
fils il s'est passé dire qu'on n'est pas
habitué
nous européens c'est à dire que je suis
allé en arménie et je sais que c'est
très difficile puisque tous les membres
de l'équipe de france sont tombés
malades un jour
donc c'est très très difficile donc là
pour peu que robert est originaire et
bien fou tu accordes tournoi et donc est
foutu la performance en restant
immédiatement d'accord alors il ya aussi
un championnat du monde des vétérans
entend peu parler un petit peu puisque
on va retrouver des vétérans fameux
comme le fameux time time and of wwii le
même qui avait perdu contre fish art 6 0
et
à l'époque il avait bien souffert contre
contre l'américain donc effectivement
time and off et bien est toujours
présent sur sur la ceni chicane même si
aujourd'hui
effectivement il est un héros qui
avoisine les 2400 ont donc sans son
niveau aa baissé avec l'âge mais quand
même aujourd'hui time and off est encore
là et bomba sur ce tournoi sa
performance est pas mal du tout
puisqu'il a mené le tournoi jusqu'à la
dernière ronde est donc là il se fait
distancer si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
mais juste un demi point des deux
leaders donc il est dans la course et
time anaf à mon avis est remonté je le
vois bien gagner je le vois bien gagner
ce championnat du monde des vétérans
taïwan au freinage d'or c'est un peu la
même génération style and off lui aussi
a inventé une sicilienne qui
malheureusement n'est plus jouer donc
échec pour taïna 9 succès pour un âge
d'or est par contre il a inventé un
système extrêmement forts qui a été
utilisée énormément par kasparov par
karpov pablo de binic par tout le monde
c'est le système contre la nive défense
ni de vinc avec eux trois et à 3 donc un
système qui est extrêmement utiliser
encore de nos jours et ça a été inventé
par tania 9 d'accord à noter que pour
participer à ces championnats du monde
vétérans il faut avoir plus de 60 ans et
là on revient sur la définition des
chaînes comme un sport qu'on ça explique
pourquoi il ya échappé vétéran n'a plus
la même pêche ont pour jouer les parties
parce qu'il faut vraiment vivant leur
année c'est plus difficile à 61 corse
n'y voyez cornouailles se maintient dans
l'est il était dans les trente meilleurs
mondiaux il ya encore un an de cela
alors qu'il a largement passé les 60 ans
oui tout à fait donc entre news alors
pourra venir mais c'est important c'est
à sydney donc le fameux match entre à
nantes déchire offre donc c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire des échecs
que il va y avoir un match d'échecs
en démonstration aux jeux olympiques
donc ça a lieu dimanche au village
olympique viswanathan anand numéro trois
mondial exact shirov et ça sera à suivre
en direct sur le site de la fidh et
alors c'est effectivement quelque chose
d'excellent pour les échecs de
fantastique puisqu'aujourd'hui les
échecs sont reconnus comme sport arrive
sur les jeux olympiques
donc c'est bien et à la fois c'est un
petit peu décevant parce que bon c'est
qu'un match il n'y a pas d' aller retour
donc ça c'est un petit peu le côté
négatif mais bon quel succès quand même
cette année pour les échecs donc à
suivre très bientôt puisque ça commence
le 24 mois il dimanche
et donc je ne sais pas que ça commence
et ça finit le 24 ans et j'utilise une
partie rapide c'est une démonstration
c'est toujours dur à jouer 20 minutes
chacun ils sont dépassés - l'australie
pour faire une semi rapide donc les
éléphants semi rapide qui va
probablement être le plus connu de
l'histoire des échecs
oui peut-être peut-être en tout cas
c'est annonciateur d'une nouvelle ère et
chicken voilà alors en tout cas alors
est ce que est ce que la question qui se
pose éventuellement sait si les échecs
de bienne olympiques on peut peut-être
en parler de deux secondes on peut se
poser la question et loi si les chèques
deviennent monétique ou prochaines
olympiades dont qui auront lieu je sais
pas où d'ailleurs aussi prévu des
prochaines vous savez les prochaines
olympiades non je suis mal je pense et
pékin où paris en 2007 prochains jeux
olympiques on va dire puisque olympiades
en interne pour les échecs
est-ce que ça va être un championnat
individuel ou est ce qu'ils vont
reprendre les championnats par équipe
dont il va faire système coupe c'est
très probable qu'il fasse un système
coupe puisque le championnat est un
système coupe la coupe du monde est un
système coupe alors pourquoi est ce que
les olympiens trpa1 système coupe
d'accord maintenant papa par équipes
alors donc ça serait un système qui à
mon avis ça va être individuel parce que
par équipes c'est très très lourd même
c'est 160 pays qui amène 10 joueurs
ouais c'est lourd même même pour un
village olympique
ça nécessite quand même
un énorme espace sur dix jours
effectivement avec des mois des moyens
techniques qui sont bons qui sont
évidemment considérable pour les jeux
olympiques je pense pas qu'on accorde
une telle importance au jeu des chefs je
pense très sans que ça sera par
progression par paliers bon cette année
c'était un petit essai on essaie
d'introduire le jeu d'échecs comme sport
auprès de la population
c'est de présenter un petit peu faire
découvrir un petit peu ça l'année
prochaine ce sera peut-être quelque
chose d'un peu plus grand mais je pense
pas qu on atteindra 2 308 dans quatre
ans par dont on est très précis ce soir
donc je pense pas que dans quatre ans on
est 40 pays représentés des équipes de
quatre ça va y aller petit à petit en
papouasie progressif de presse on peut
dire que la semaine prochaine avant de
parler en loin l'événement de la semaine
tout à fait tout à fait ça sera ça on
vous repassera les inferno de lautier et
puis évidemment on vous en dira plus sur
kasparov chronique puisque le match
approche c'est dans trois semaines que
ça va commencer
oui donc on vous en vain commentaire
complet sur ce match l'état de forme des
joueurs
comment ils ont travaillé pour quoi oui
parce que ça lui mardi suit nous aurons
quelques réponses sur le festival donc
major mygale nage nov on sera six cars
pop a joué des sicilienne quant au
devenir des carreaux kahn voit l'affirmé
nous dira donc je crois qu'il y avait
également puisqu'on parle d'olympiades
oui un événement aussi important
l'olympiade donc des jeunes ouailles qui
a eu donc lieu en ukraine et on le
capitaine de l'équipe française était
jean-luc chavanon le reporter choc de
diagonale puisque jean louis qui a fait
plusieurs reportages pour des gones al
notamment à dortmund cette année donc il
accompagner les jeunes donc ces années
c'est pour vous faire participer les
jeunes des pays alors c'est à dire que
c'est une équipe française lite on va
dire puisque c'est moins de 16 ans on
n'aura peur ou une équipe assez forte
puisque on a des bons joueurs de moins
de 16 ans notamment marie ce vague wii
qui est une bonne joueuse mais qui est
en l'occurrence un des meilleurs joueurs
de moins de 16 ans mais qui fument comme
de france toutes catégories on n'a pas
envoyé meilleur mais je crois qu'on a
quand même terminé 10e si je me trompe
pas avec shahbanou comme entraîneur
c'est plutôt une bonne performance
d'accord on le dira à vrai dire
effectivement l'équipe a terminé donc en
milieu de classement
ce qui est vraiment remarquable parce
que bon les équipes en lice est
extraordinaire russie d'ukraine
on a battu la géorgie on a battu
l'ukraine et donc ces résultats ont été
commentés également sur le site de
cannes échecs dont j invite les
internautes à visiter le site est très
bonne performance de l'équipe de france
dans des équipes pareil très bonne
performance voilà on termine sur cette
très bonne performance de vienne qui
annonce un avenir brillant et notamment
pour les prochains jeux olympiques on
l'espère on vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine donc avec compte rendu
détaillé de ce match entre attendait
shirov à sydney et puis évidemment les
préparatifs pour le match kasparov
kramnik voilà la semaine prochaine
et vous
oh